[Música]
aterrizamos en la capital de portugal
lisboa y se encuentra ensamblada
especial a la cumbre de la onu de los
océanos son marina colorado marina
último día entonces esta conferencia de
los océanos que ha sucedido durante toda
esta semana
pues han sido cinco días en los que los
alrededor de 6500 participantes han
podido asistir a eventos paralelos
diálogos charlas con un tema en
particular la importancia de proteger el
océano para poder tener un planeta
saludable
las temáticas han sido muy variadas pero
con un hilo conductor es que las
soluciones y el conocimiento está ahí la
tecnología en su gran medida también lo
que hace falta es dinero para
implementar estas soluciones que
soluciones pues bueno bueno es que la el
océano puede ser una gran fuente de
energía y es que según la agencia
internacional para la energía esté las
olas de este recurso podrían abastecer
de energía a todo el planeta lo que pasa
que la tecnología todavía no está lo
suficientemente
desarrollada eso haría que podríamos
llegar a ser de emisiones de cero en
todo el planeta para el año 2050 otro
aspecto la solución comida el océano es
una fuente y diversa de comida no solo
de proteína animal sino también de
proteína vegetal las algas son un
recurso muy poco estudiado o muy poco
explotado en muchas zonas del planeta y
finalmente y no menos importante es que
el océano es la mayor esponja de dióxido
de carbono que tenemos en el planeta así
que el océano lo que dicen es que tiene
todos los ingredientes o todo lo
necesario para poder alcanzar las metas
del acuerdo de parís y aunque en esta
conferencia no se han llegado a acuerdos
legalmente vinculantes y ha habido
cientos de compromisos voluntarios que
son promesas que han hecho
organizaciones o gobiernos en cuanto al
cuidado del océano entre ellos a
destacar los 1250 millones que el banco
de desarrollo de américa latina caf va a
dar en préstamos para proyectos que
protejan los ecosistemas marinos y
costeros de latinoamérica y el caribe
chile pidió una moratoria de 15 años
para evitar la minería del fondo del
océano una minería que sacaría minerales
preciados para las baterías que tanto se
necesitan para los coches eléctricos
pero de lo que no se sabe las
consecuencias y finalmente manuel macrón
anunció que costa rica y francia se
quieren ser voluntarios para ser los
anfitriones de la próxima conferencia de
los océanos que será en 2025 pues marina
la paradoja de nuestra sociedad si están
los recursos y la tecnología para ir y
vuelta el espacio sólo por diversión y
no para usar la energía de nuestro
planeta